Jack Smith is the man who led the
investigation into Donald Trump he
recommended he be charged the first
former U.S president to face Federal
criminal charges we have one set of laws
in this country and they apply to
everyone the 49-page indictment lays out
the case against the former president in
Stark terms it alleges he kept documents
which showed the defense capabilities of
the U.S and its allies documents which
showed where the U.S defenses were most
vulnerable and it says by storing them
where he did and how he did he put at
risk U.S national security the safety of
the military and intelligence assets are
laws that protect National Defense
information are critical to the Safety
and Security of the United States
and they must be enforced potentially
spending the rest of his life in jail
Donald Trump dismissed the charges
against him as politically motivated
this has been going on for seven years
and they can't stop because it's
election interference at the highest
level the indictment says the FBI tried
to recover the documents from his
Mar-A-Lago home but Trump asked his
lawyer to hide them destroy them and
tell everyone he was cooperating fully
Trump announced his new presidential
campaign back in November many
speculated then he did it hoping to
avoid any possible charges in any of the
several cases he faces
his defense took a hit when his lawyer
resigned just hours after defending him
on TV this is not a criminal issue under
the presidential records act this whole
thing is a civil dispute at the most
Republicans even some of those
challenging him for the party's
presidential nomination are still giving
their support and I'm deeply troubled to
see this indictment move forward
has repeatedly denied any involvement in
the management of the case President
Biden have you spoken to attorney
general Merrick Garland yet
Donald Trump is planning to push ahead
with campaign rallies he'd planned for
the weekend organizers say there's been
a rush of people who want to attend
security at the Florida courthouse where
the hearing will be heard will be
increased over the weekend and at places
like the FBI headquarters and here at
the Department of Justice Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera Washington